I'm great Drake with Rotten Tomatoes
here at Universal Studios Halloween
Horror Nights I guess you could say I'm
bad what according to all of them
recently saw the none and that was
pretty terrifying scariest movie
character of all time obviously Mike
Myers scariest movie character of all
time
Halloween in theaters October 19 Linda
Blair possessed non possessed she's a
sweetheart but says dear mother of the
Lord the best lesson I've learned from
the horror movie is to never go follow
the sound don't throw the effing knife
away thank you
throw the knife away throw it away the
weapon away forty years of people going
like why'd you throw the knife away
don't go inside right or one of those
cliches body part I'd missed the most I
think would have to be my leg when I
dance I lead with my right and if I lose
my right leg just I look really bad no
one would ever invite me to their
wedding reception that is literally the
worst thing that would happen to you if
you crashing weddings at a wedding near
you yeah police don't take my body parts
please please don't take my body parts
don't take them I need all of them what
body part would you miss the most
and for your app visit Universal Studios
Halloween Horror Nights in both Orlando
and Hollywood be terrified all across
the country
[Music]